ce nom peu plus tôt
ça va faire j'ai pas fait de repas digne
de ce nom de fusées sont mêlés que tu as
mis si c'était stupide poison est censé
attirer les satyres pour voir les
satyres ici la fin l'as rome a vu encore
plus mauvaises
je pourrais tout manger si tu n'étais
pas si clair tu peux m'expliquer
pourquoi tu porte une robe se passe une
très mauvaise journée permet de s'en
aller mais les autres ne croiront jamais
autrement je te suggère que je suis
déguisé là je suis dans sa troupe de
survie laïdo qui fait des gens en tout
cas marc toi depuis que je suis là
j'essaie de rester entier pour trouver
le moyen de lui prendre la poison
discrètement alors tu as trouvé si
j'avais trouvé tu crois que j'ai encore
ça sur la tronche trouve ça joli